the installed era a focus on Tierra
Mobile is targeting a facility
Ella Medicine it is a great honor to
introduce the Nobel laureates in
Physiology or medicine professor Randy
Schekman
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
ladies and gentlemen on behalf of my
colleagues Jim Rothman and Thomson HOF I
am deeply honored and humbled by the
recognition you have bestowed on us
today I view this occasion as one of the
great moments of my life one that I am
thrilled to share with my wife and
children my father and family friends
colleagues and the students of mine who
made this day possible
I wish particularly to acknowledge the
Nobel foundation for its recognition of
basic science this year's laureates in
the natural sciences reflect the value
of curiosity driven inquiry unfettered
by top-down management of goals and
methods government funding of basic
research in the United States started
after World War 2 with a transformative
report science endless frontiers written
by Vannevar Bush the science advisor to
presidents Roosevelt and Truman he wrote
scientific progress on a broad front
results from the free play of free
intellects working on subjects of their
own choice in the manner dictated by
their curiosity for exploration of the
unknown freedom of inquiry must be
preserved under any plan for government
support of science that freedom of
inquiry nourished the careers of today's
laureates Jim Rothman and Tom suit Hoff
discovered the molecular basis of
neurotransmitter release at the junction
of nerve cells and between nerve and
muscle cells the molecules they probed
are the targets of a potent toxin
produced by a poisonous bacterium that
causes botulism no one could have
predicted a practical application of
this knowledge yet judging from the many
handsome near-perfect faces here this
evening
some of you may have personal experience
with Botox the commercial term of this
toxin the uses of Botox extend well
beyond the cosmetic including the
treatment of debilitating their muscular
diseases such as afflicted the concert
pianist Leon Fleisher who after 30 years
of paralysis has now been restored to
the concert stage the work in my
laboratory probed the molecular basis of
protein secretion in baker's yeast we
had no notion of any practical
application of this work and after we
learned that yeast cells use a pathway
fundamentally the same as in human cells
the biotechnology industry applied this
knowledge to engineer the production of
commercially useful quantities of human
proteins one third of the world's supply
of recombinant human insulin is produced
in yeast again it is likely that some of
you here tonight benefit from this
discovery and technology many of you can
recount similar stories where an
investment in basic science has resulted
in a direct application to medicine and
technology and yet we find a growing
tendency for government to want to
manage the discovery with expansive
so-called strategic science initiatives
at the expense of the individual
creative exercise we celebrate today
Louis Pasteur recognized this tension
long ago before the trend toward managed
science he wrote there does not exist a
category of science to which one can
give the name applied science there are
sciences and the application of science
bound together as the fruit of the tree
which bears it and so to the memory of
Alfred Nobel for his vision to recognize
individual scientific achievement and to
Louis Pasteur and the beverage industry
he saved and to yet another example of
yeast fermentation technology
I offer a toast to our gracious Swedish
hosts skull